Newt Gingrich said he's knocking he
would never touch Social Security or
Medicare Gingrich told three wives that
he would love them until the day is was
over and he lied at least the two of
them you think there's a there's space
for another black Republican like trm
Howard in an in the American landscape
in his day Republicans and Democrats
have one thing in common
a common commitment to public
convictions everything they say they're
gonna do it's all repealing all of the
progressive legislation that passed the
twentieth century America's one-sixth of
the world's population but consume 94
percent of the hard drugs that this is
about drugs not about jobs you can't you
can't have one without there he will
only pick the lesser of the evils then
you deserve the evil of evil from public
schools from Community College because
our nation must unleashing the greatness
of every child today what was more
importantly four billion dollars for a
race to the top or the ten billion
dollars that Obama gave to teachers
right after that what's really important
is to have schools that work and make
sure that we have the resources for that
those resources that happened this last
summer were absolutely essential to make
sure school districts could continue the
work for kids in an unprecedented budget
crisis do you believe in school choice I
believe in public schools having the
resources they need
I don't mind public charter schools to
make a sharper but I don't believe in
private how many more how much more
resources are they did do parents need
more choice in education what parents
need is a great neighborhood school for
all of their kids and our union is
they're trying to get that for every
single parent
do we need more shovel-ready jobs
absolutely as the stimulus worked
absolutely tarp good idea bad idea it
was necessary auto bailout good idea bad
idea terrific ideas AIG bailout good
idea bad idea how much government is too
much government I don't know we have yet
to see too much for me your wonder one
of the premier high tech entrepreneurs
what can the government do to create
jobs there's a lot that they didn't do
to get us into this situation in terms
of letting the private sector get away
with murder are you still eating no I'm
going fast now for two years
yeah thank you Reverend Sharpton how do
you keep the weight off the recession
feeling better feel better somebody
asked me say you've been fasting 40
years what does your doctor think I
might document day at 30 years if you
said Governor Christie we'd have no idea
that no mostly fact Christie are you at
your ideal body weight absolutely you
feel that the Tea Party is motivated by
racism I do is soak up the diversity the
love the working together that we enjoy
today they want to change this country
and we as one nation stand up this day
and say we will be there on November 2nd
how much is the Tea Party motivated by
racial issues rather than idiom ideology
well I'm not in the Tea Party so I can't
tell you you know what's in their minds
or what's in their souls but I know what
they say I struggle with big are they
racist well look at their signs do you
think America is in a better place now
that in 1963 when you were here Oh
surely first of all I have a better
and it's a less racist country that it
was absolutely it's America in a better
place than it was in 1968 no not at all
no no because you got more people
exposed to the truth then in 1968 you
had more folks that skip poverty didn't
see state not eat going back and then
once you show me on TV what the good
life is is hard for me not the warning
are we at a better place than when you
released on the beach well I didn't
release on the beach but when Neal did
yes who knows who knows all right thanks
very much nice talking with you